good evening and we begin tonight with
another big test at allegiant stadium as
the actual venue there played host to
guns and roses thanks for joining us at
11 o'clock i'm denise valdez so we were
out there with concertgoers yet again to
see if this whole situation with the
parking is getting any better 8 news now
reporter or mana joining us now live
from the stadium in orco what's the
verdict
well denise it was definitely crowded
down here at the legion stadium for guns
and roses with thousands of fans coming
out but those we spoke to said that they
didn't really have any issues with
parking or traffic they were just really
excited to see the concert
fans flocked to allegiant stadium friday
to see guns and roses i've been waiting
for this day forever i love it i love it
this party
but first they have to navigate the cars
and cones all around the venue because
it's a jungle out there we got dropped
off right over there some concert goers
opting to get a ride to avoid the
traffic until they figure all this stuff
out because this is the first year that
they are having fans until they get it
all figured out it's going to be a lot
of issues hold on folks event workers
and police keeping things moving even
with some people getting dropped off in
the middle of the street while previous
events at allegiant such as the garth
brooks concert and the gold cup final
were played with parking problems many
said things went smoothly for guns and
roses we chose our parking facility
first before we came down and pre-paid
parked and it was wonderful everything
has been better than expected that's the
best compliment i can give you still
this couple decided to stay overnight at
a hotel across the street this is a
place to stay whenever we need to come
in here that's what we're going to do it
so that was our plan while everyone is
hopeful things will get better still new
they'll come up with stuff vegas they'll
figure it out man they always do some
will stick to their plans for future
events probably get dropped off
now clark county commissioner michael
naft has previously told eight news now
that they are working on making things
smoother but he added that the situation
out here will continue to be a process
of learning and growth throughout the
whole season reporting live at
allegiance stadium tonight orca mana 8
news now